how are you doing i'm doing excellent um
i was actually i was actually there last
night at the your little the cast and
crew little thing
uh you know at the at the hotel um what
was it like actually to see everybody
again
because i would imagine it's been a
little while
it's been a little while a couple of
months so we finished uh season six in
may
so it's not been a long time
but obviously uh these uh
so-called fab five every time we see
each other we're like
it's like we're seeing our family we are
in a family they bonded uh
so well from day one that
no matter what i think 10 years from now
20 years from now just like friends
every time we see each other we were
ever so happy to be to have the
opportunity and
the chance to
see each other again yeah uh i'm curious
if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've been in what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
if they haven't seen anything i would
definitely suggest
in terms of what's happening in today's
world i would definitely suggest house
of sand and fog
but if they are
sort of
highly educated
as they call them nerds or people who
are interested in
uh
um
[Music]
sort of what's what's going to happen in
the future
uh the people who have invested
most were studying
uh but you know
the the picture in the future of the
humanity
and
uh then i would suggest definitely i
would suggest expanse the expanse
because
this is the best
example of today's world by the way
experience has never been this close to
reality
before
and this year this year is just
when we started they said
well this is a um this takes place in
100 in a couple of hundred years from
now
in the course of seven years it has
become the story of today i mean think
of think of the proto molecule think of
the
um
you know hostage
the refugees crisis think of
some politicians trying to make
alliances i mean it's i i watch this and
then i watch the news and i don't see
the difference between them it's like
it's been experienced speaks for today's
world not 200 years from now
oh believe me uh the expanse is one of
my favorite shows on tv which is why i'm
very happy to be talking all to talking
to all of you today um so i do have to i
just want to start
going further i really do want to give a
thank you to amazon for saving the show
and for putting it on for multiple years
and so i guess i'm curious when you need
to buy something now do you feel an
obligation to buy it on amazon
yes
the answer is yes
not only that but also i got myself an
amazon credit card
to show my loyalty
and sort of
yes of course it's inevitable
you can't help it i'm like if i can buy
it on amazon i will buy it on amazon
well because yeah because day one when
we started the show i was hoping that
the show would fly and would be shown to
the people of the world and when
amazon picked us up i was ever so
thankful and grateful to amazon for the
fact that this show is about the people
of the world it's not about a certain
nation therefore it should have been
sown to the people of the world
but i'm glad that amazon stepped in
pretty early and was with us
uh to the end yes i'm grateful to them
too
i i am too i i actually think i i'm
willing to bet that jeff bezos watches
the show just because of his interest in
space i'm willing to wager uh he was
instrumental in you know in why it's
still on the air yeah
you know absolutely
so uh i don't want to ask anything
generic but i've seen the final season i
know i can't spoil anything what are you
actually allowed to tease about what's
coming in the final six episodes
well it's um the final is what i love
about the final is that
uh
decisions
are more thoroughly thought of rather
than being rushed into
everybody is trying to be more careful
and
[Music]
approaches are different this year
even avasarella is looking for a very
diplomatic way to solve problems rather
than rushing into a decision or going to
war it started in season five
when she resigned and decided to leave
the table
uh and when everybody was willing to go
to another war
uh
as of then
she's been sort of uh
been being more careful
um more
towards
uh diplomacy
than than fighting with one another
forming alliances
and yeah i love that i wish i was going
to happen in the real world
well i was going to say it has to be
like great as an actor to play someone
who's gone from this side of the
spectrum all the way over here who's
learned over these years uh to you know
the repercussions if you will of
the act anyway they must be really great
for you it was amazing and that's not
very good that i was aging at the same
time that that was what i was aging so i
went through the same thing
you're not that old yet and not my age
to be
uh to fully fathom that what happens
when you
when you age when you grow older
your point of view changes
uh it's
it becomes more sort of
on the side of i'm trying to understand
what is happening rather than i do
understand what's happening and i have a
solution for it no
i don't want that anymore one of the
things you obviously have some great
stuff with bobby this season and the
relationship between the two characters
is uh i really love it and fans do as
well can you sort of talk about the
relationship with bobby this season and
how it's changed or grown what i love
about uh
avasarala's relationship with bobby this
season is the fact that they have sort
out
their issues
the issues that they had with one
another from the very beginning
obviously
they both come from different societies
different upbringing different
everything but i was sorry
the reason absorber likes bobby so much
is because she sees
a bit of herself in avasarala when i was
old i was that age that's why she would
she loved to recruit her and she did her
best to bring bobby to her side
and
for bobby it was always the you know the
um issue of trust should i trust this
woman she's
being famous for being manipulative or
you know
uh
well
i'm glad that finally
we could sort that out
um the trust issue is very important
when people want to help one another or
back each other up
they need to trust one another
i'm curious for you after spending this
many years playing the character and
making the series what was it actually
like how did you get the last script for
episode six did you uh did you guys read
it together as a group or was it a table
read what was it like actually reading
that because it's the culmination of
everything well it's interesting
great question i didn't read it and
year one uh stephen suggested to um as
demonstrate that if we're not doing
anything because we're all alone living
alone in toronto home away from home he
said if you guys are not doing on
sundays
why don't we get together and read
through the next episode and we all said
that's a great idea
six years of that we kept doing that
which i'm going to miss a lot and uh
season one is that when the last episode
came i said i'm not going to read it i'm
going to read it with the kids
on sunday
and on sunday
you could hear
each other going
we could say we were all emotional but i
read it with them and
immediately i fell in love with it i
thought
wow they have done because we were all
worried about the very last episode
and we were hoping that it would be you
know
larger than life above everything else
that we've done before
and they once again our brilliant
writers prove to us that
yes it is it is
the end is just incredible and
we all sat there after usually after
readings we will oh go home or go have
something to eat but we all sat there
and
there was a
for while there was silence in the room
and we were all thinking
trying to take it in that
this is the last one
yeah you also have some good stuff in
the last episode so it you know there's
uh yeah i can't talk about it but i'm
just gonna say you have some good stuff
um what was it actually like for you now
there's one thing about reading that
script but what was it like actually
like the last what was your last day of
filming like and did you possibly borrow
anything extra from set that day knowing
it was your last day
not that day
but
months before
i took a candelabra small one
and i told everyone i said i'm taking
this i'm i'm not stealing it i'm taking
it
but uh john hanson our amazing costume
designer was kind enough to give me a
few of my
uh costumes
which i love and adore and i would love
to share two of them with the museums
whoever asks for it first will get it
yeah your your costumes on the show are
really um i'm gonna use the term
fantastic
you're absolutely right fantastic she
did an amazing job oh a hundred percent
um who do you think there's always
people behind the scenes that don't get
enough credit on the making of a show
like this who do you think is like an
unsung hero that someone needs to be you
know what i mean like someone that you
want to sort of single out and say they
deserve some credit
honesty
is the curators of the show
mark ferguson and hawk utsp
they started it
when hawk osb called me and told me
about this character
and i didn't have time to read it he
just i did it it was an ability for me
to read he just told me
who this character
was and
what they did their perseverance they
never gave up they
did everything they had in their power
to make it possible for us to make this
this season and season one they were
with us but then they were so busy
obviously they're such an amazing
writers they're the writers of iron man
and children of men so you can imagine
they couldn't spend a lot of time with
us after the first season but i think
those are the ones that we haven't seen
enough
in our later
sort of seasons
which i would love to
thank and tell them that
how grateful i am to them for for having
me on this show
oh and and i'm grateful for them also
for making it um what do you actually
think you're going to miss the most
about playing this character
the writers
i wish i had those writers who would
write for me in my daily
you know life
honestly sometimes people
you know say something or uh you know
with
families uk tehran iran whatever i'm on
the phone they say something and i'm
bewildered i'm looking for an answer and
i cannot come up with an answer and i'm
thinking
where are you guys i wish you could
write for me and i wish i could come up
with an answer easily like i'm sorry
guys every time
but
i guess yeah that's the that i would i
would miss the writers
and their writings
yeah before i run out of time um there
the the reviews on arcane have been like
huge everyone has just been raving about
it um can you sort of talk about what
drew you to doing some work on that and
what you know what i mean i know exactly
what you mean i had no idea that again
this was going arcane was going to end
up like this
it was a game
when i joined and i love doing games
for the fact that i don't have to put on
a makeup or
you know change my clothes i go in with
a ponytail no makeup
and i
act
uh the thing that i love to do ever
since i was five years old i get into
that room and i get to act like uh
psylocke want to
and i really enjoy this so it was a game
but then i was told that
i'm going to talk to two audiences one
is the
uh audience that would watch it as an
animation the other one the
players or the guardians that are
playing the game and i i was so happy
but when i watched it
i loved it it reminded me of when the
this genre called hyper realism started
in paintings and you know a pop sort of
art
it's it's very very realistic it's
really like hyper realism sort of take
and this animation which i loved and
yeah it's it's incredible how it's
how great it's doing
a hundred percent um i gotta stop there
i'm just gonna say seriously i really
loved your work uh in this role thank
you for giving me your time thank you so
much thank you